[Music]
for example this one didn't sell at all
it's a very strange coffee table book
we'll take a look at it it says your
co-workers after they heard you got
fired
pictures of your Cobra yeah
what an ass why would you want that look
at these people they're perfect
oh he took off his headphones to hear
about you yeah so glad that you're gone
yeah yeah sorry that's a pile again
here's a holiday-themed one that didn't
sell and I guess I could tell why it's
called elves about to jump off their
shelves these are dry stoves that are
just about ready to go and then look at
this guy right here he is the
authorities have been called and then
this one did jump oh boy yeah yeah
pressure of being Santa's narc was too
much yeah like the crowd reaction to
that one the elf facedown in his own
blood
here's one here's a book regrettable
[ __ ] stamps transplant look at that
that's just
this I don't get why that didn't sell
that's there that one this was a bad
idea right here I love municipal noise
or hi you don't want to be and then this
last one just you know what I mean
that's that it's funny we talked about
this whenever Herzl right right and I
said I don't know that people are gonna
laugh at that and I was told by
top-flight professionals people are
gonna love this I'm talking about top
profession oh yeah what it was my idea
there now one I think Regis would be
happy I think we can agree just would be
fine with it yeah here we go look this
book is called moments later they were
electrocuted now folks I'm gonna say
some of these are kinda dark
yeah oh you think that's bad take a look
down south
keep in mind these didn't sell yeah
these didn't sell these are bad items oh
oh boy this crowd sounds like it's on a
roller table is to horrify yes I love
this one or oh I didn't sell it just
called rocket dogs places to go and
things to do
rocket dogs this one very strange it's
also in the dog series right it was a
whole table just about dog dogs are very
popular too sure let's pretend yeah
anyway look at this one dogs with
terrible poker faces these Hector
[Applause]
and then look at this guy
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography